foreign
with the news that we have more Hunter
Hunter chapters dropping for like
literally the first time in freaking
years I think it's time we dive into the
most recent complete Arc of this series
which takes place directly after the
anime ends so yes everything in this
video follows straight after the final
episode with gone and is Daddy-o and it
pretty much just elaborates on
everything that is going down inside of
the so-called Dark Continent if you want
me to cover even more of the recent
Hunter Hunter stuff push this video to
like 5K likes and leave a comment down
below as it truly helps out with pushing
my content to a bunch of new amazing
people anyway enough of that let's get
to the start of the hunter hunter Dark
Continent Expedition Arc so as we kick
things off the little green man himself
beans it was actually you know like not
green and the manga he barges into the
zodiacs conference room shouting about a
big emergency as Cheeto at the same time
was about to make a large announcement
The Zodiacs initially think that she
awkward as the chairman but cheetah
assures them before leading Bing talk he
shows a video in which the kakin
Empire's King a large Manta named asubi
huigoro goes on Iran about bearing all
of human future dreams on their back
from thus he ends up declaring that they
the karkin Empire will advance into the
dark continents hearing this all of
these Zodiacs are taken aback aside from
Kansai who's completely clueless about
the Dark Continent to start worth gel
explains that the dark continent is a
place that can't be found on the world
map but it's where other human-like
beings and other magical beasts Thrive
meso storm also adds him that every
other time humans have also tried to go
there disasters have fallen upon them
back at home due to this happening a few
times 200 years ago the five leading
nations of the world called the V5 made
a treaty to never go back there chill
explains that 30 years ago kakin
technically became a new nation by
taking advantage of an incident and
jacking the country's monarchy turning
it into a parliamentary democracy at
which time they likely did not renew
their treaties or frankly just threw
them away as the zodiacs continue to
discuss Baines interrupts them pointing
at the screen and stating that in fact
the really trembling part actually comes
next looking back at video it shows
nasubi as he introduces the person that
will lead the expedition to the Dark
Continent he proudly announces the
legendary pro hunter Isaac nitito the
previous chairman of the hunter
Association and states that they have
hired his son Beyond nituro to lead the
expedition to the New World The Zodiacs
are surprised once again as they all
react to the news of nitero even having
a son dude like literally never even
brought up his son once throughout the
previous 150 ten episodes of the anime
anyway Joe suggests that they verify if
it's true or not but as Beyond starts to
give a speech multiple Zodiacs
immediately recognize his resemblance to
the late chairman Beyond promises that
he will take care of everything and that
everyone will have an equal opportunity
in this new world he screams and
encourages everyone to come to kakin so
they can embark on the new Journey to
the new world beans discloses that they
were in effect two DVDs now the chairman
netido had left behind as Ben slides the
second DVD onto the table he explains
that nizotto told him to show all of the
members of these zodiacs the other DVD
if anyone came forth claiming to be a
son however getting in periston are
absent so he's unable to proceed any
further because of this though Shadow
interrupts the arguing Zodiacs to begin
her own announcement yet we aren't
exactly privy to this information as of
yet as instead we actually skip away
from the zodiacs to learn that currently
the people of the new world are blown
away with Beyond's announcement and
can't stop watching it on their version
of YouTube Beyond who's like literally
just chilling having a few drinks and
his Lea overhears that the King has been
notified by the V5 to revoke the
previous announcement and instead signed
it treaty I could literally get in the
Togashi treatment and having a book of
information shoved in his face by his
curly head friend and annoyed Beyond
decides to ignore the permissions of the
V5 about exploring the Dark Continent as
he wants to explore the unknown world
without supervision standing there and
just looking magic he says to his 10
important followers one of which just
happens to be that damn snake periston
that is willing to see a land that
nobody has ever seen before meet people
known ever met obtain things that no
one's ever touched and all by his own
volition without being restrained by no
one so skipping away from Beyond backed
over to Cheadle we learned that her news
was that they didn't actually need to
wait for getting in Paris then to see
the DVD as technically they had resigned
as members of these Zodiacs therefore
there are now only 10 Zodiacs allowing
them to fulfill the conditions and also
on top of that something that's actually
more important than the previous two the
V5 have already given them a special
assignment to hunt Beyond nessaro
elsewhere the IPA director and newly
assigned deputy secretary Steiner who
are both associated with the V5 walk
through a heavily secured hallway and
discuss the role of the organization in
accordance with the upcoming Journey to
the dark continents as they enter an
elevator the director mentions that the
gatekeeper of the new world hates
ill-mannered visitors and should the
negotiations for the karkin Empire break
down it will be very difficult to stop
them Steiner asks what would happen to
which the older dude talks about
Pandora's Box being opened which Steiner
questions as a figure of speech however
the IPA director explains that he once
thought that back when he was young and
before he had come here he then opens a
door to the international permit agency
basement that's filled with various
atrocities and corpses resulting from
the last entry into the Dark Continent
the bewildered Deputy shutters wondering
what the hell this could be to which
it's revealed that all of these
atrocities used to be human the director
hands over a book called The Journey to
the new world to Steiner explaining that
it was once considered fiction but is
now a legend Dairy text that contains
travels to the Dark Continent from
hundreds of years ago the director
further explains that all of the Run
corpses in the basement were discovered
on this side or more specifically in the
known world and none of them had ever
traveled Into the Dark Continent hence
struck Steiner to memorize every detail
of the book and identify the risks of
traveling to the new world as they walk
along through the basement one creature
slams hits the glass which takes Steiner
in Surprise the director explains that
this one creature is the Lone Survivor
in their facility but it is no longer
human the creature does not need
sustenance like humans do and it has
already lived for 50 years being
completely self-sustaining every attempt
humanity is made at exploring the dark
continent has resulted in the inflamed
home and bringing home a Calamity of
mass destruction with them the director
continues that the creature was once a
hunter who was exposed to a virus that
renders him immune to death meanwhile
The Zodiacs watched his second DVD with
Foreman chairman the big OG knittero
explains that his randomly mysterious
Sun Beyond once traveled to the Dark
Continent and brought back new threats
that resulted in considerable casualties
so he forbade further attempts by Beyond
and the hunter Association until after
his own death this little explains that
he's the only set foot there twice and
when he was young but he personally
realized that the strength required to
remain there wasn't what he sought the
new world was a harsh battle against
Mother Nature itself when no Victor
exists Nitro declares that he wants the
hunter Association to explore the Dark
Continent before his son telling them to
overcome the risks of the new world in
return with hope as a difficulty as
undisputedly a though quickly before
ending he emphasizes that this is a
request rather than an order and is
completely up to them to choose whether
or not they go cheetah accepts the
mission saying that since it's in order
he literally had no other choice but
states that no other hunters in the
organization should join them soyu and
Kansai assert their opposition to
beyon's hunt stating that it makes the
race to the New World unfair as Beyond
has been preparing for decades for this
moment one of the zodiacs asked if any
of them have actually thought about
going to the New World before with one
of them mentioning that ging is the only
one they can think of who has the
ambition to go to the Dark Continent
Jill says that if geng does help the
race will be fear for argument's sake
otherwise kakin and Beyond will have a
big hit start as all of the zodiacs
argue over the next course of action
Bane suddenly receives a call from
someone mysterious with all of the
zodiacs having followed beans it's
revealed that Beyond nestedo had indeed
just called him and now appears before
the zodiacs standing there he firstly
gives the what's up to Big beings as
obviously he's been around for years
then he instructs them to call the V5
telling them that they have captured
Beyond tennisadow leaving all of the
zodiacs shocked with the absolute
unpredictable turn of events elsewhere
Steiner begins his Forte into the
prolific book that he is supposed to
memorize there it's shown that five
threats Humanity has previously brought
back from the new world are the
codependence of desire which is a
gaseous life form a sphere that protects
their mysterious ruins called the
Botanical weaponryon a monster that
infects its prey with a homicidal desire
known as the snake hell bell this one
here is my favorite the trade-off
between life and pleasure known as the
Beast that keeps people as its pets and
finally endless despair disguise this
hope zobe the immortality disease after
reading all of this Steiner only
reflects thinking that this indeed is no
place Humanity should ever Venture so
again Peck with the zodiacs it's showing
that Beyond is now being kept within a
cell while cheetah interviews him and
the rest of the zodiac standby and watch
sitting there in a seemingly helpless
situation Beyond makes a prediction The
Zodiacs will end up releasing and
joining him in his expedition to the
dark continents chilo quickly dismisses
the idea though calling it an
unrealistic illusion but still Beyond
tells her to hear him out before the V5
make their own reports having placed a
recorder on the table she proposes that
the conversation shall be recorded
Beyond accepts however as she stares at
him she knows Beyond is technically on
the offensive or she and the zodiacs had
to decode and figure him out elsewhere
the V5 and deputy secretary Steiner
discussed the previous Dark Continent
Expeditions it's shown that their world
is actually located in the center of the
massive Lake Mobius of which itself is
also located within the dark continents
in their records there are 149 attempts
to challenge The Voyage but out of there
only 28 people survived from the five
trips that actually managed to return
out of them Beyond is the only one who
was still alive today though said five
voyages that had returned were also
unofficial and took place after the V5
form the enviability treaty so mankind
has never officially succeeded in making
a round trip to the new world out of the
28 survivors only three were able to
return to the ordinary lives which makes
a survival rate of 0.04 percent one old
ass hack of an employee asks about
guides and another member answers that
there are a race of people called The
Gatekeepers who summon a being to help
transport people to the Dark Continent
as a few people talk amongst themselves
a larger man interrupts pointing out
that any talk of risk only adds fuel to
the fire for countries and businesses
that pour money into the stuff and they
hope that they'll get to return another
employee implies that they need to know
the official way to be able to stop
cocaine from advancing towards their new
world signer explains that article 4 of
the Ewan chartered basic relations
treaty states that International threats
Clauses seven through nine prohibit
active involvement with contagious
diseases biological hazards and unknown
menaces but if it's determined that a
nation is at risk then the use of force
including military intervention is
permitted and as we all know from the
freaking Chimera ant arc when the Army
is involved they are dropping some
freaking Next Level biological Weaponry
probably implanted inside of some poor
old dude anyways anyways Steiner says
that considering this to end this
situation in a peaceful manner it is
necessary to invite kakin to the V5
they're through there they will
reorganized as they 6 and unofficially
support kakin's Journey to the new world
making them also look good in turn
Steiner continues explaining that there
are tons of uninhibited Islands in a
neutral zone inside of the far ocean
boundary so they can also pretend that
they are a part of the new continent and
have civilians spend their lives there
while they can actually leave The Voyage
to kakin but only on the condition that
their members are carefully selected
which makes sense as obviously you
wouldn't want some weak nobody's rolling
around on the Dark Continent possibly
putting others In Harm's Way like
everybody just needs to be able to hold
their own in a fight back over with our
Hunters as Shadow and Beyond continue on
the interview Kansai is just utterly
perplexed about the conversation and
asks someone to translate it for him
Sato simply answers that Beyond got a
ticket to the Dark Continent in exchange
for making karkin's King a historical
hero but because the V5 doesn't like to
lose they are making the zodiacs babysit
Beyond Kanto asks if it's good for them
Angel explains that technically it's
good and bad as if they succeed it's
possible they'll be allowed to hunt on
the continent back inside the cell
Beyond insists that Cheeto contact the
V5 hence us that they'll say tell beyond
that they'll accept a supervised voyage
and that The Chaperone will be the
hunter Association after a moment
Cheadle accepts under the conditions
that he's telling the truth but first
they have to confirm some stuff walking
outside of the room she asks misai to
contact the V5 instantly it's confirmed
just like Beyond said that this hoodiex
will indeed go to the Dark Continent
with Beyond even against their will when
kanzai gets confused again shell
explains that Beyond will be transported
to the Dark Continent as a prisoner but
somehow he'll probably Escape leaving
them with the task of fighting off
threats maintaining Beyond and somehow
stopping Beyond conrades from also
interfering and their mission once
everyone begins to leave sacho offers to
watch over beyond what Sheil accepts she
then turns to the imprisoned man and
tells him that he should be prepared as
it will be a long imprisonment adhering
this Beyond laughs as he says he'll wait
as long as it takes earlier on over at
The Mating place and as everyone left
that room Steiner thinks aloud about how
their official stance is that the book
you read recently as a writer's fantasy
but in actuality the book is the most
important piece of criteria on the
entire planet having listened to this
explanation the IPA director cracks up
and slaps him on the back while replying
that he'll be a great manager just like
him someday he then states that of
course an honest world would be best yet
pace is much more of an important Manner
and some other place the black whale
transport ship is presented to the
people of kakim it is said to carry
about 200 000 people and in the next
five years King musubi has declared that
he will seen 500 ships to the Dark
Continent which totals around a hundred
million people men is actually trying to
exterminate the lives of a hundred
million innocent civilians without him
even realizing ain't no way a normal man
is surviving on this freaking domain of
death anyways anyways the TV reporters
continue to explain that the maiden
voyage will carry Beyond The King and 14
princesses any civilians will be picked
by Lottery and those odds are currently
only one in 1300 which is you know look
extremely low according to the news
reporter here and a recording studio
nearby reporters discussed the Beast
during no one to mankind which is that
book that all of the hunters have that
rank certain threats they could go up
against in a fight anyway a female
reporter asks someone to explain to them
in terms that they would understand how
dangerous the C-Class ranking is the men
state that it's things like beers sharks
poisonous snakes and stuff you might
come across if you're unlucky they might
turn face or any worst case scenario
another anchor this state their online
opinions declare that the Dark Continent
surely must have a rank b or a creatures
laughing in response the random man says
well of course nobody can count them out
completely but these people also assume
that mankind has never even ventured
there in the past because dangerous
creatures exist oh my Lord the amount of
information Togashi is actually shoving
down our throats right now anyway he
continues explaining that many ancient
Romans describe the calamities caused by
going to the continent science has
concluded that these Mass casualties
were from infectious viruses and now
with modern medicine they will easily be
able to prevent such problems from
occurring on top of that the stuff they
do find is much more likely to be hiding
miraculous compounds they can help
mankind Advance further than it ever has
before as the broadcast comes to an end
that dude declares that this will be the
greatest gold rush in all of human
history having rolled up as the
broadcast was finishing on the TV game
freaks the big man himself arrives in
the Leer of Beyond's base and confronts
Paris in Hell King explained that if the
government doesn't answer to Beyond's
taunt and send them to the Dark
Continent paristan in response would
force their hand and send in 5 000
Camira ants he continues telling him
that he will no longer allow Paris and
to do as he pleases and tells him that
he is going to play with him personally
until he begs him to stop periston looks
at gang with his deep dark eyes and
responds confidently asking he's finally
going to pay him some attention gang
who's like visibly disgusted with Paris
and just answered that he might just be
doing it for his own fun back over at
the hunter Association she will contacts
one of the ogs of the series liorio over
the phone and invites him to become a
member of these odx she explains to the
hunter Association thinks his skills are
best suited to fill the position and
they absolutely need his help in the
upcoming Mission when leori who implies
that he will turn down the offer cheetah
continues to say that there is a medical
study waiting for him and she will be
the head medical Professor herself
hearing this Leorio who in most cases
would have just rejected the offer into
accepting as he knows that there's no
chance this will ever happen again and
his life he thanks her for granting him
this opportunity however he just has one
request he asks Cheadle if there is
still another position available on the
zodiacs because if there is he is
someone he'd like to recommend for the
post and we all know who that icoverting
chain wielding King is back over in the
layer of Beyond's base which by the way
has the scary girl May's picture now
featured on the TV not sure why Takashi
decided Chuck this on here but holy a
place to the whole feeling of like this
mess in here having a scary ass pic of a
child featured on the television there
periston states that the hunter exam
will begin soon and then he knows
Genghis aware of the 5000 Chimera ants
he has hidden away as a backup to force
the V5 into the Expedition he thinks
cheetah will separate the hunter exam
from the organization which parison
disapproves of when gang asks and why
you would want to destroy the hunter
Association despite feeling attached to
it parison asks him to prove it starting
from his motives ging starts to explain
that person is seeking something new
that could entertain him as the
association has started to Tire him
because of this King assumes that Paris
and thought it was time to move on and
find new targets the fastest way is by
scattering the khmera ants across the
world while also opening the previously
illegal route to the Dark Continent he
continues to say that periston's
underlings might easily pass the exam
and become organizational members
however he cannot see the link between
why parison would brandish the threat of
the Chimera ants against the association
he continues by proclaiming that
periston and he are kindred spirits and
their ideas are always a tiny bit of the
Beaten Track Paris then Smile weakens as
he concedes that ging is spot on he
reflects it normally people find
happiness and loving and being loved but
he feels happy most when he is hated and
he continually feels this irresponsible
need to destroy the things he loves most
malevolently he wonders aloud if it is
all that weird with ginger replying that
periston is completely off the beaten
Mark and asserting that they are
different in that respect curly tries to
ask a question but is completely shunned
by getting much to his dismay userman
the sajimo looking wannabe stands up and
threatens the former boar zodiac but
before he can even do anything he is
lifted up by gang and imagines his own
face being carved in by the latest
plethora of punches coming back to
reality the dude realizes he probably
would have just witnessed his own death
as gang then orders him to get lost if
he truly understands what happened then
quickly looking around the room he finds
a robotic girl and corner and asks her
if she has the highest ranking person
perison interrupts his intruding though
and calls himself the obvious number two
within the team standing there gang
observes for the surprise that people
are not ranked by strength before
releasing the poor dude he almost beat
the out of parison objects that he
has been underestimated but again coldly
states he would end up killing him if
they were to fight however he would
continue to display his disgusting smile
and laugh unless his very Spirit Was
Defeated he then declares himself number
two and challenges anyone they might
oppose him elsewhere mizai the big cow
the Zodiac heads out in search of
Kurapika as that was obviously the
person liorio had recommended for the
position once arriving at Kota pika's
Place Linton informs him that he is
currently out but can leave a message
for him if he'd like misai though
literally insists to wait man's instead
like can over coffee and don't worry
I'll manage with the milk which is
actually insane when you think about it
anyways the three men didn't block his
pathway calmly though the Cal King pulls
out and then shows them a warning card
which indicates that X of violence are
not allowed when the main photo moved to
attack him misle uses the card to
restrain the men's movement most likely
a part of his knee ability called cross
game sitting down in the corner of the
room he tells the men that they'll be
able to move any moment but warns them
that if they try and resist more it'll
continue to immobilize them finally the
bartender interrupts telling him that
Kurapika is actually in the basement he
warns the cow though to not anger him as
he is really upset about something that
concerns their group specifically before
he can finish explaining though could a
pika himself appears asking what are the
noises and who was the random man where
in a cow uniform in his house meso storm
introduces himself from the hunter
Association and asks Kurapika if he's
heard about the news regarding the Dark
Continent Expedition he invites him to
join the zodiacs under the request of
Leorio the kurupika quickly declines
telling him that he is busy mizai though
certainly brings up the prolific Scarlet
eyes which incites anger and could have
Peak her seen in his own skull at either
light or the fire of all of his Fallen
clan members he then makes this chains
appear and threatens mizai telling him
to choose carefully his words from now
on miso storm reports that on the web
there is an illegal website in which
criminals will sell real items through
six months ago someone posted a video in
which a number of scarlet eyes are
visible having seen this video himself
Kurapika already knows about the content
with the Nerds however the cow king then
reveals that they managed to find the
owner of those eyes something that could
have Pika and his crew were completely
unable to do he tells him that they
would all like him to join the zodiacs
and take part in the Expedition to the
new world an expedition that will last
approximately two months he asks him to
carefully study the ins and outs of The
Proposal before coming to a decision
kuropika considers the offer thoroughly
before thinking about how it's a
priority of his to recover the stolen
eyes because of this he joins on this
spot so that he can find out the true
identity of the person who owns those
eyes after a moment mizai pulls out a
picture and gives it to kurta Pika it's
explained that this man in the photo
completely dropped out as the 4 Prince
of the Kagan Empire a Man called Slender
Nick huigoro and he is the confirmed
owner of the stolen Scarlet eyes
standing there kuropika recalls how he
acquired the previous sets of scarlet
eyes that are now in his possession
going over all of the people he's had to
take down and his head finally ending on
the man who was his current Target the
son of a king remembering Pyro from his
childhood Kurapika realizes that his
journey is finally beginning he wonders
where he may go a place where he's
greeted or won in which he may call home
however he sadly remembers that he no
longer has anything like that at all in
his life back and Beyond's Lear the
members are still doubtful of having
gang as the second in command behind
Beyond two members even decide to fight
against him that game quickly offers
them money instead he promises the
double Beyond's pay to the members and
will pay them in advance apart from that
he says that he has nothing else to
offer them and also has no other request
to make of them he asks if they have any
questions and not to hesitate as you'll
answer them with pleasure another member
who seemed skeptical over whether or not
he'll get paid in the first place asks
if he's sure he doesn't have any other
requests to make of the group to which
king again tells them no and to trust
them King says that if they allow him to
be the number two they'll all be paid
accordingly and the case will be closed
that skeptical member ends up giving
gang his account number and only a few
moments later after being visibly
surprised at the money in his account
leaves the lair with the other members
note him that he probably won't come
back geng asks periston if he has any
other objections in which parison
actually says that he's happy but the
turn of events back over in the hunter
Association building Leorio manages to
get in contact with kuripika who is
currently traveling by car with the cow
King mizai kuripika asks him about how
gonze doing and liorio just brushes it
off saying that he's fine but he needs
his support at the association after
some Antics between the two boys could I
pick it into the call and thanks mizai
for the connection to the prince though
he knows his abilities will not help
much for them during the Expedition meso
storm warns Coulda Parker daddy Prince
has a darker side still he knows he'll
probably act recklessly either way when
confronted with him but he still tells
him to try and use the safest method
possible and avoid detection could a
Parker hearing this though reassures him
that he has dealt with monsters and
human shells which is also so true like
kurapaka is a pure genius when it comes
to taking down an enemy who's stronger
than him man was so confident with the
Phantom troop he brought a damn Spade to
his fight with uvogon who is like the
Triple A size anyways elsewhere and for
the first time in this Arc we actually
save you Lawman himself gone as he tries
to activate his nin but is surprised
when he finds out that he can no longer
access Earths sadly though we skip away
from the previous main character of the
series over to the evolved version of
gong ging as he details the previous
five threats of the Dark Continent to a
few members from Beyond's Expedition
team he explains that these threats are
stronger than the Chimera ants and
people have no counter measure against
them he continues that the victims of AI
and pep have been pound and his sixth
three might return back with them after
their Journey one of Beyond's allies
asks like why in the world they would
want to even travel there is there
anything they could even possibly gain
from actually going and getting kind of
like blows their minds he goes way more
in depth on the distances around the
continent where to find materials around
this new world that can physically
change the world they live in already
and the base protecting these priscious
locations oars or materials continuing
he explains that the hunter Association
had also organized an expedition with
netido and a few of his mates in the
past but there is no given official
information on this trip according to
nisiro himself though that land is just
utterly monstrous and all of these
Adventures were supposed to serve as a
warning in order to prevent Beyond or
his son from traveling to the Dark
Continent Isaac and the V5 placed a ban
over the place and any ship that would
be seen towards the new world would be
hit with the Seal of the Forbidden
standing there geng asks the people in
front of him if they are still ready to
take up the challenge but interrupting
them the member from before who just
received the money and gapped it turns
stating that he's ready in front of a
shocked group the younger bloke tells
them that all of his money was spent to
save his younger sister in the hospital
and because of that he's infinitely
grateful to him he agrees that Genghis
now undoubtedly second place within the
team then the moment that I love most
happens Yang having found out that Deuce
history tells him that he can't afford
to let him die any longer so he will
also make sure that he can keep the
amounts Beyond off at him gingers like
an actual chair I'm assuming he means
that he'll let the younger man stay in
safety on the Homeland while still
letting him get the fair payday from
Beyond as well dudes making up for all
of the random shitty popcorns through
throughout the main story with other
people it looks like anyway I'm not too
sure they're just named Curly where they
asking about the reference of all of the
information and the dark continents and
Jung explains that every generation has
their Nutters but 300 years ago someone
explored the shores of Mobius all on
their own and this person read the
Memoirs of his explanation called the
memories of a new world traveler east
and west yet Yang sadly explains that
until today only one copy has ever been
found with not the slightest trace of
the west book in UEA after mesha and
another team member give two possible
reasons as to why it might not be found
game gives a possible third one so damn
insane I had to double check out bread
on the correct text he says that the
book is still currently being written as
they speak and as everyone reacts with
surprise over this bizarre statement he
continues revealing that the author as
no one other than Don freaks the ancient
ancestor of gone and gang freaks which
is actually freaking insane like the
Revelation that another ancestor or
another member of the gone family is
still somehow alive and actually on the
Dark Continent still writing this book
is it's just mental to me I absolutely
love the idea like does time dilate
differently the further you go out and
the Dark Continent or something anyways
skipping forward to a phone call between
Father and Son surprisingly we're gonna
informs his father that he is not able
to bring any Aura out but gang tells
them by saying that walgons aura most
probably is coming out as it was when
they were Atop The Tree he just can't
see it himself pretty much meaning that
gone had now returned to a normal person
he then states to him that he should
just be thankful for all that has
happened to him as he could have easily
lost a lot more he then advises gone to
take this opportunity to figure out what
he can do as he is now gone hates his
father's advice and returns to whale
Island reuniting with Mito and helping
her whether housework just like he used
to way back at the very beginning of the
series man I love the absolute like
Nostalgia hurt this little island gives
me I haven't seen the Hana anime in
years but it was one of the first ever
series that I fully completed like every
single episode of and just knowing that
our little man has finally come home
wraps up that side of his story
perfectly for me anyway anyway during
dinner Mito questions gone asking him if
he was bummed out for not being able to
go with game gone replies to this by
stating that even if he did go with gang
he probably would get in his way however
it probably would have been a different
matter if he could still use nin as man
was massive he then confesses that now
he realizes that he didn't really want
to meet gang but finding him in fact was
just his goal when Mito agrees with
gone's explanation of his father she
says that Yang didn't have the qualities
of a father and gone cheekily replies
that it must be father like son and
maybe he wasn't actually cut out to be a
son at all to watch Mito violently
rejects gone cracks up laughing as well
before explaining that he was obviously
just joking when he comes down he stares
into his glass and says that it didn't
cross his mind that he should stay with
him because he's his dad but if he had
been able to use nin and had felt how
truly awesome and Powerful he is then he
would have most likely wanted to go with
him Mido sums up the conversation by
stating that he was now stuck with her
and leaves the room only to return with
two large piles of paper and forming the
young man that these books were all the
documents gone was going to have to fill
in to Which con recoils screaming out in
a comical manner not realizing he ever
had to do desk work within the
association back at the base and having
ended the call with gone gang encounters
a member who informs him that the EXP
Edition team had divided into two groups
those who won't take gang's money and
those who will yet since Paris and
considers getting being number two now
they won't object to him being sick and
now as well but then states that all of
this disunity will lead to chaos So to
avoid it they decided not to listen to
any of his orders until at least
everyone accepts the money as gang had
also guessed they were hired by Beyond
through Paris then so King considers
them to be mediators and it did not
matter to them if he looked down on them
for this another member then confesses
that even if they ganged up on him there
would be no match against gang yet gang
kind of feels that something just ain't
right with his entire situation and
replies by saying that they don't have
to lie as he knows they're all indeed
experts as young States has reasons to
believe that the members of Beyond's
Expedition team are Specialists pretty
much just explaining their entire damn
Dynamic of how their team Works pasting
confesses to himself that Yang's thought
process was similar to him and that this
was the first time he had actually
started to grow to hate someone think
gang drops a damn bomb and says that the
10 members here obviously as in everyone
in the group so to solve their issue of
payments he tells person to tell the
other members he'll pay them up front as
well as periston replies telling him
he'll let everyone know he thinks to
himself that he wants to see what he'd
do to someone he truly hates meanwhile
over in a banging dance club somewhere
in a city too Sicky ass peasant females
that were invited to the hotel room of
the prince who has the Scarlet eyes
after a quick glance to each other the
girls both accept the invitation now
arriving at a massive Hotel entirely
owned by the prince of kecken they are
filled with ore at the pure beauty of
the house asking if the prince lived
there all by himself the prince applies
to this by saying that he never really
feels lonely as he always invites people
on over and asks the girls to tell him
about themselves yet as the majority of
you probably foresaw trendernick is
latesting having a shower alone then
later a bath while talking to someone
named Mark on the phone he complains to
him about how the girls were oblivious
to what was happening around the world
am I only enter interested in fashion
and you know they're good time stuff
sitting there were the four soaked in
blood the prince then asks him to send
in another pair of women this is
probably like the dark side that means I
was referring to when talking with
kuripaka earlier when talking to
kuripika earlier most likely due to the
dude's overwhelming influence within the
kakan family and throughout probably the
world they can't actually arrest or even
probably tell him to stop his vile ax
meanwhile in her office cheetah is
ordered by the IPA director to make
Beyond sign a contract saying that if he
breaks the rules even once he will spend
his entire life in jail he states that
he doesn't want to imagine what would
happen if Beyond does manage to escape
and then on top of that makes a
discovery known to the whole world
declaring it as something that he found
on his own ethos was to be the case he
threatens cheating telling her that her
future won't be so bright if this
happens heading back down to the cells
with a new contract Cheeto hands it to
Beyond and tells him to read it he
agrees with the rules of the contract
reading the majority of it aloud and
saying that it was exact like he had
already predicted with him not objecting
Beyond ends up signing the contract
before striking the pin into the
contract itself causing it to stick into
the pad below him he then ominously
explains that only three more things
remain qualifications the means and a
contracts back in the car mizai ask
kuripika about what he'll do with the
prince after they take the Scarlet ice
back to which could opika replies that
he'll yield to most demands all he wants
is to get the eyes back means I
questioned him again this time ask him
what he'll do if the prince resists but
could a picky replies by saying that
he's encountered two people in the past
who said that they would rather die than
give him what he wants he then states
that none of them were actually dead now
but both of them had a change of hearts
and says that he was sure the prince
would follow suit having reached the
hunter association's office that you
were greeted by a surprise liorio and
chidor who's also just like you know
with him cheddle leads them to the room
and watch the other Zodiacs are seated
she then Begins the meeting by informing
The Zodiacs at these specific nations
are the ones that make up the V5 which
because of kakin's recent mess has now
turned into their V6 with them as the
sixth seed she then states that the V6
had tried numerous times to enter the
Dark Continent but it failed each time
due to those five threats I've brought
up multiple times throughout this video
already she then proceeds to inform them
that the danger rank of the five threats
has risen from rank B to a which even
surpasses the kamira ants who are a
b-level threats Cheadle then reveals
their objective to capture at least one
of the five threats survive the trip
back home and deal with beyond all on
the process which if you think about it
is just pure Insanity as the big man
nituro himself was barely able to even
defeat Miriam in their battle even with
the help of man-made Weaponry like the
dude still regenerated I don't know the
strength of the other members in the
zodiacs as of yet obviously this is just
Insanity to me at the moment seeing them
all go there and I can't picture the
Oreo being able to take down or even
assist into facing AA rank 3 It Anyway
Sheed within inquires asking if anyone
has a question to ask raises his hair
stating that he has a few when given
permission to speak he asks all of the
zodiacs that they have identified all of
Beyond's allies who are inside of the
association he then proceeds to explain
the reasoning of his question stating
that Espionage was expecting his
father's death instead of having to
actually defeat him himself he must have
planned his involvement within the
association with someone beforehand he
also on top of dropping that bomb
manages to confirm the theory for the
zodiacs that paristan and the temp
Hunters were some of Beyond's allies
mizai realizing that kuripika's
statements could lead to certain
complications leads him outside and
reveals that he and cheetah had come to
the same conclusion as could a pika did
and requests him to not mention anything
about moles in front of the zodiacs
again as it would just put them all on
alert to which Kurapika agrees when the
two of them then return all of the
zodiac members revealed the roles they
will play and their Voyage to the dark
continents but we ain't going to go in
depth about every single one of their
names and why they are a part of the
zodiacs because this video is evolving
into something that's way too long for
the amount of chapters that they should
be like having never read the Hana manga
before the amount of information stuffed
into the story could easily create just
like a novel by itself as their in-depth
Point anyway enough of my crazy ass
ramblings now we actually skip ahead one
month and find ourselves back and
Beyond's Lair as gang shows the people
there a cheeky little trick called pip
play which by the way is just the
ability to manipulate pip-sized balls of
nin and select little animals on your
hand while the other members try to
master the Trek curly approaches gang
and challenges him on a vocabulary match
to see who knew the most words of the
ancient Kappa language that begin with N
as you could imagine gen comfortably
wins this contest and in turn curly
finally accepts him as number two Paris
and then suddenly shows up and informs
gang that all of the Assassins that were
sent into the 289th hunter examination
failed and acknowledges the ability of
his replacement and the zodiacs just
then Moira along with two other Hunter
exam participants arrive and comment
that he like obviously referring to
kotapika as rumored to be able to read
minds when question about his early
arrival he stayed okay so he didn't even
need to see the results to know that he
didn't pass having sat down he then
orders gang to go away as he knows that
he was previously on the association's
side he gain correction by saying that
when it comes to the idea of how freedom
is considered he was more closer to
Beyond than the association he then
states it is clear to help Beyond be
free but he can't give Paris in a pass
as his true goal is to help Beyond and
deter the snake periston mahu reply to
this by saying that he just didn't buy
it all the usamin interrupts him a
filming gangs claimed that he wasn't on
the association's side Musha becomes
surprised by the member's testimony
asking him since when did they accept
gang as a friend the member replies to
this by saying that he still hated the
dude's guts but let's just sit back and
see how it goes for a few days just then
the other Hunter exam participants
arrived saying that they won't be
waiting as Beyond is the only boss and
they don't care about some irrelevant
number two they then present gang and
Paris them with two options either Paris
to leave the Expedition team or gang
leaves the Expedition team another king
no person agrees with the two options
though and instead ging produces a third
option while Paris then produces a
fourth either the Assassins will leave
or the Assassins will die instantly
though Maher's henchmen used conjured
guns to shoot Aura bullets directly at
gang and periston who easily managed to
dodge out of the way and Escape through
an underground passage gang complains
about them having a bad temper to which
parison says that he's not as crazy as
he expected King tells him to shut up as
well as perison actually provoked them
in the first place hearing thus the
slight rat cheekly jokes that he was
just going along with what gang had said
after gaining a bit of distance between
the two parison asked if they should
fight back twitch King agrees but he
only wants to do it gently he analyzes
their abilities noting that there are
meters who have to conjure guns to fight
seeing him preparing to attack person
asks if it's okay for him to watch him
use his ability but because because
ging's like literally a chair and not a
dad he responds affirmatively saying
that it ain't no problem watching with
the Gaze of Amazement Paris them
Witnesses gang reproduclear Oreo's
remote punch by continuously slamming
the ground over and over again allowing
him to send a blast of Aura through the
ground towards the approaching Broods
before suddenly appearing above the
surface and pameling the trio of
unsuspecting mercenaries perison asked
if his ability as the copy kind but King
explains that it just has this random
talent to be able to imitate someone's
ability if it's the physical type and he
has been hit by it continuing on this
Brooke Shield of dominance King surmises
on how liorio must have been palpacing
his patients and using his Aura like an
ultrasound through this he assumes that
his inability was the result of
experimentation with aura and tapping he
literally flexes on Paris and some more
and again he uses the same
ultrasound-like technique to discover
the two enemies on the other side of the
wall and mentioning those that enemies
have a tumor or like blood clot inside
of them that can't be reached with
normal medicine he then shoots two Aura
bullets that travel through the wall
completely taking down the unsuspecting
henchmen after using its same ability
again he confirms that there are no more
enemies coming after them parison
speculates it has been because they'd
given up but King disagrees stating they
must assume that their mission was
completed he reveals that in fact he'd
known all along that the whole thing was
actually staged by parastin and the
biggest mistake in his attempt to full
gang was that the angry guy with the
Mohawk didn't bring up the fifth
possible choice of both gang and Paris
and leaving although he admits if he had
brought that choice up he might have
actually gone with it hidden states that
he's gone along with periston's show
only because he felt bad for the ones
who were forced to play it but he says
if the former rat wants to see his real
abilities he has to come at him himself
back in the lounge now as the henchmen
clean up the remnants of the couch they
blasted to bits before muhu expresses
his perplexity about their shame having
been found out since he thought his
acting was extremely good however gang
moxom plainly imitating one of his lines
and irritating the mercenary in a joking
manner King states that mura should be
more worried about his soldiers than his
acting since they are far too weak to
face the Dark Continent alone mainly
only as backup Reserves at best sipping
on his drank by the G this mercenary it
looks like he replies that's exactly
what they are and these soldiers who
also aired in their two-sing state their
duties are limited to reconnaissance
artillery support and covering fire
while the shooting itself will be
covered by Gollum gang recognizes him as
his symbiotic type nin user watch
American firms before explaining that
Gollum himself consciously powerful
heavy weapon that is manned by an
emitter who creates the bullets this way
both euripon and the bullets are
stronger than they would be separats
gang understands Gollum was also the one
who gave the Firearms to the henchmen
and praises the adaptability of detector
mura continues explaining that for men
to long-term group Warfare carrying real
guns loaded with nen bullets greatly
increases the efficiency on the
battlefield Gollum and these 10 other
men with assault and Recon duties make
up the Stonewall Squad the legionary
unit which came out of the loop of Civil
War without a single casualty gang is
impressed by gollum's abilities and asks
its real name but a distorted voice
replies that Gollum is how it's been
called by its comrades and declares that
further inquiries will not be answered
confused and curious Mora informs gang
that he's known Golem for over three
years and still doesn't know anything
about who Pilots hurts King admits that
to be honest he was expecting it as the
Golem had been giving off it don't talk
to me Vibe getting down to business now
gengh asks Maura to convince the other
members of Beyond's group to take his
money since he's in charge of all of the
divisions the mercenary response that he
was fine with having the hunter as
number two until he offered to give him
money him along with all of his men
think soldiers should value each other's
trust more than anything the rumor that
some of them could be brought would
later than being ostracized the fact
that Yang was tossing around his money
as if it had no consequences was a cause
of great anger to him heirs like the
title of a book or the place whether the
remote is put on the table something had
already been decided and mirrored and
trying to change it so carelessly only
had negative repercussions to the point
many members even considered quitting
more within demands that can explain
himself but the hunter can't he can only
say that he is sorry and since he can't
take better money from those who would
accept it it as it would just add to
this mess He suggests to settle the
matter with donations to the Norwell
fund for families of Fallen Soldiers
which by the way if you're confused this
whole like trust fund type Foundation
thing supports families of Fallen
mercenaries so obviously this hits home
for Maura right here taken by surprise
mura asks him if he is serious as by
opening a grandchild account he won't be
able to refuse a requests by the
grandfather accounts getting replies
that it's for the best as it shows his
determination and won't risk stirring up
any weird rumors more inquires why is he
so keen on giving them his money NKU
most that he honestly just doesn't know
he often ends up in the kind of
situation where he talks a lot and then
wonders why he's done it but probably
the main reason was that he knew the
Expedition members aren't the kind of
people who would be brought by money so
he knew that if they were to take it it
would actually mean they have accepted
him perhaps it was also because he was
happy there were other fools like him
around he confesses he'd plan to go to
the Dark Continent on his own but the
first caused by Beyond's own expedition
made possible so he's very angry at
Beyond comparison but at the same time
aware that Beyond had been preparing for
even longer than he has when it came to
his base he had not straightened out his
feelings yet and only wanted to blow off
some steam he doesn't even remember how
the whole money topic originated Masha
though remember like the thumb looking
dude from earlier while he jumps in on
the conversation to give his take on
what happened Masher explains that ging
himself offered it while he was arguing
with periston initially mesha believed
he was just a troublemaker with a
perogative facade and the tendency to
try and manipulate others but during the
discussion he heard the two former
Zodiacs speaking about Isaac nasudo and
gang's feelings toward the dark
continents mesha and Marion were ready
to fight and the event disorder Rose but
since they prioritized solving their
problem they recognized that ging's lead
had undeniable merits mirror like I
don't know if I'm saying this guy's name
right it seems German to me and I don't
know German that well so he doesn't
exactly understand how this is related
to the money King though admits he was
just trying to be cool about it and at
the time didn't foresee that it would
cause such an upper War although his
relationship with pariston is
complicated he's not concussing anything
he just wants to Thorp Harrison's shames
and help Beyond be free Golem joins the
conversation asking mura why he had not
told them sooner the mercenary awkwardly
responds that in order to quell the
disorder had to get gang to acknowledge
his shame he urges Golan to try and
understand his feelings yet to no avail
causing gang to feel like this is all
his fault as well in the end Mora
accepts and says he'll talk to the
soldiers provided that the money does
indeed go to the Norwell Foundation plus
despite getting being the number two in
the operation it will be the mercenaries
that will be giving the orders to
everyone on the battlefield and those
orders are absolute genk agrees more
comically answering sir yes sir which
like obviously Hella reminds me of gone
honestly dude is just the grown-up
version of gone on that world smoke
level anyways what he made a finally
settled mura asks periston if the ones
who are returning to the base will
accept gang and quickly receives an
affirmative answer person tells gang
that since the filtration failed him now
sent his money to the list of comrades
he is transmitting to him and
congratulates him for getting this
amended position amongst the group
however as we know he gives a Multiverse
level theorist and states that his
authority is only a name as everyone
will continue to do as Paris and says
either way he's still willing to let
parastin lead as he wants to watch but
the letter declines wanting to actually
see how gang indeed handles things gang
smirks back and declares that he will
not hold back at all I'm just going to
count myself off here again as well this
is the next Arc after this one may never
actually be completed depending on like
how frequently Takashi releases these
chapters hopefully the next 33 that are
confirmed will be like able to complete
the succession Arc but if not be sure to
let me know down below what fights
throughout the succession Arc you want
me to cover and honestly just push this
video to 5K likes and I'll break down
their Arc into part so I can at least
cover some of it anyways back over with
Big C at the final part of the 289th
hunter exam there she asks the
applicants whether they know about
beyon's expedition to the Dark Continent
and if they knew how and when did they
get access to their information the
participants were also asked if they
would explain the information and the
best way to a person they did not know
about this and on what the merits of
receiving this information beforehand
were and another room could a pika and
misoi storm are trying to verify what
the applicants say he concludes that the
first examiner he doesn't know the
second murder has mixed truth and with
his lies and the third one is hiding
extremely important information Kurapika
is actually surprised at the number of
people that have cleared the
thermography and lie detectors he then
explains his abilities to measure storms
and the limitations that they have
obviously I'm not going to go like super
in depth on all the stuff that was
explained years ago in the anime so
after explaining all that he thinks
about the possibility that if the enemy
has someone on their side they can
manipulate another's memory then his
chain would likely not work as that
person wouldn't even realize they were
lying to begin with skipping away over
to Prince t with the crazy name well he
gets a call from his elder brother big
Benjamin who's this J dust dude and man
you know also on top of that it was also
wrestling a freaking lion Benjamin
informs him that their father has
decided that whoever survives this
Expedition becomes the new king thankful
of God cylinder Nick warns his brother
that he is the one who is going to be
king after the court ends he then gets
another call from one other bodyguard on
another phone like behind him dude
there's like a stack of like 10 phones
there Theta informs them they're all
five of his staff members have actually
passed the hunter exam she explained
that if they lied or had any information
from the hunter Association they would
have actually been rejected so they told
the truth she confirms that the
bodyguards are the princes that haven't
participated in the exam were Benjamins
and Tysons or the first and sixes
princes respectively on top of that all
of the bodyguards from the seventh
Prince lucidus failed the exam having
heard everything turned to Nick orders
Theta to return to her defensive duties
and tells everyone to get an in-depth
understanding of the black whale back at
the hunter exam mizai confirms that
there is no one within the zodiacs that
has the powers to manipulate somebody's
memory he continues to say that within
the previous odx there were three
factions with gyung and Paris then being
exceptions he knows all of the powers of
the hunters within his own faction which
include bow to buy Cheeto and ginta but
he obviously doesn't know the powers of
the other members that you were
obviously suspicious of jundai and mura
and wonder if they were purposely sent
into the hunter exam as decoys by some
powerful spies miso infers that this spy
may be a traitor within the zodiacs
since perison left so soon after losing
the presidential election hearing this
could a pika volunteers to find the
traitor using his chain ability and will
wait in a nearby room while he confronts
them suddenly re-entering the room Mesa
abruptly confronts all of the zodiacs
about there being a possible spy within
the group he asks everyone to once again
reveal their abilities before he can
proceed any further Kansai starts
reaching out over having a shower's
ability not phased though the cow zodiac
explains that it would have actually
helped Beyond if he had met him before
he would have gladly tried to make his
dream come true and wouldn't have
changed his mind after seeing in the
Chairman's final video however it's a
question of sequence not betrayal and
that's why he's asking him to reveal
their abilities continuing miso Reveals
His abilities to them all and explains
how it works exactly elsewhere the mega
bankura Pika watches the whole thing on
a monitor in a separate room via a
hidden camera he uses his sneaky ability
to quickly scan these odx passing off
ones who aren't spies however he
eventually finds out that the traitor is
indeed the monkey say you so that there
does officially bring us to the very end
of what is the hunter hunter Dark
Continent Expedition Arc or whatever you
want to call it there's so much that
goes down through this art obviously
ending on a massive Cliffhanger with
Scio being called out as a traitor by
cuta Pig here as I've said you know let
me know down in the comment section
below what fights from throughout the
succession Arc you want me to go over
and if you want me to actually just put
it out in Parts push this video to 10K
likes so that I know you want there and
just leave you know like comments down
below let me know what other series you
want me to go over and what kind of
stuff but anyway if you guys are on your
own here and haven't subscribed already
they make sure you hit the Subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of
there for now streaming professional
degenerate dear Volo and I will see you
all in above bye